when i received the nobel prize for
literature i got to wondering exactly
how my songs related to literature i
wanted to reflect on it and see where
the connection was i'm going to try to
articulate that to you and most likely
it will go in a roundabout way but I
hope what I say will be worthwhile and
purposeful if I was to go back to the
donning of it all I guess I'd have to
start with Buddy Holly but he died when
I was about 18 and he was 22 from the
moment I first heard him I felt a kin
I felt related like he was an older
brother I haven't thought of resembling
him but he played the music that I loved
the music I grew up on country-western
rock and roll and rhythm and blues three
separate strands of music that he
intertwined and infused into one genre
one brand and Buddy wrote songs songs
that had beautiful melodies and
imaginative verses and he sang great
sang in more than a few voices he was
the archetype everything I wasn't and
wanted to be I saw him on e but once and
that was a few days before he was gone I
had to travel 100 miles to get to see
him play and it wasn't disappointed he
was powerful and electrifying and had a
commanding presence I was only six feet
away
he was mesmerizing I watched his face
his heads
glady tapped his foot his big black
glasses the eyes behind the glasses the
way he held his guitar the way he stood
his neat suit everything about him he
looked older than 22 something about him
seemed permanent and he filled me with
conviction then out of the blue the most
uncanny thing happened he looked me
right straight in the eye
and he transmitted something something I
didn't know what and it gave me the
chills
I think it was a day or two after that
that his plane went down and somebody
somebody had never seen before
handed me a little record with the song
cotton fields on it never I could change
my life right then and there
transported me into a world I'd never
known it was like an explosion went off
like I've been walking in darkness and
all of a sudden with darkness was
eliminated it was like somebody laid
hands on me I must have played that
record a hundred times it was on a label
I'd never heard of with a booklet inside
with advertisements for other artists on
a label
Sonny Terry and brownie McGhee the new
Lost City Ramblers Jean Ritchie string
bands I'd never heard any of them but I
reckoned if they were on this label with
red belly they had to be good so I
needed to hear them
I wanted to know all about it and say
that kind of music I still had that
feeling for the music I'd grown up with
but for right now I forgot about it
didn't even think about it for the time
being it was long gone I hadn't left
home yet but I couldn't wait to I wanted
to learn this music and meet the people
who played it eventually I did leave and
I did learn to play those songs they
were difference in the radio songs that
I'd been listening to all along they
were more vibrant and truthful to life
with radio songs a performer might get a
hit that the role of the sax or followed
the cards but that didn't matter in the
folk world everything was a hit all you
had to do is be well versed to be able
to play the melody some of these songs
were easy some not that a natural
feeling for the ancient ballads in
country blues but everything else had to
learn from scratch and I was playing for
small crowds sometimes no more than four
or five people in a room or a street
corner you had to have a wide repertoire
and you had to know what to play and
when some songs were intimate
somebody had to shout to be heard by
listening to all the early folk artists
singing the songs yourself you pick up
the vernacular you internalize it you're
singing it in the ragtime lose work
songs Georgia sea shanties Appalachian
ballads and cowboy songs you hear all
the finer points and you learn the
details you know what it's all about
taking the pistol out putting it back in
your pocket whipping your way through
traffic
talking in the dark you know that
staggered Lee was a bad man and Frankie
was a good girl you know that Washington
is a boudoir town and you heard the deep
pitched voice of John the Revelator and
you saw the Titanic sink in a boggy
creek and your pals at the wild Irish
roller and the wild cowboy you heard the
muffled drums and the fights too played
lowly you've seen the lusty Lord
Donald's ticket Nash and his wife's and
a lot of your comments have been wrapped
in white linen I had all the vernacular
down I knew the rhetoric none of it went
over my head the devices the techniques
the secrets of mysteries and I knew all
the deserted roads that had traveled on
to I can make it all connect and move
the current of the day when I started
writing my own songs of folk lingo
was the only vocabulary that I knew and
I used it but that's something else as
well I had principles and sensibilities
in an informed view of the world and I
had had that for a while
learn it all in grammar school Don
Quixote Ivanhoe Robinson Crusoe
Gulliver's Travels Tale of Two Cities
all the rest typical Grammar School
reading they gave you a way of looking
at life an understanding of human nature
and a standard to measure things by I
took all that with me when I started
composing lyrics and the themes from
those books work their way into many of
my songs either knowingly or
unintentionally I wanted to write songs
unlike anything anybody ever heard
and these themes were fundamental
specific books that have stuck with me
ever since I read the way back in
grammar school I want to tell you about
three of them Moby Dick
all Quiet on the Western Front and the
Odyssey Moby Dick is a fascinating book
a book that's filled with scenes of high
drama and dramatic dialogue the book
makes demands on you the plot is
straightforward the mysterious Captain
Ahab
Kevin with a ship called the Pequod and
egomaniac with the pegleg pursuing his
nemesis the great white whale Moby Dick
who took his leg and he pursues him all
the way from the Atlantic around the tip
of Africa and into the Indian Ocean
he pursues the way around both sides of
the earth it's an abstract goal nothing
concrete a definite he calls Moby the
Emperor sees him as the embodiment of
evil a haves got a wife and child back
in Nantucket that he reminisces about
now and again you can anticipate what
will happen the ship's crew is made up
of men of different races and any one of
them who sights the whale will be given
the reward of a gold coin a lot of
zodiac symbols religious allegory
stereotypes a have encounters other
waiting vessels presses the Kevins for
details about Moby have they seen him
there's a crazy prophet Gabriel on one
of the vessels and he predicts a Habs
doom says Moby is an incarnate of a
shaker God and that any dealings with
him will lead to disaster he says that
the Captain Ahab another ship's captain
captain boomer he lost an arm to Moby
but he tolerates that and he's happy to
have survived he can't accept they have
lust for vengeance this book tells how
different men react in different ways to
the same experience a lot of Old
Testament biblical
allegory Gabriel Rachel gerawan bilder
Elijah pay you names as well Tashtego
flask
daggoo please Starbuck Stubb mother's
Vineyard the pagans are Idol worshipers
some worship little wax figures some
wooden figures some worship fire the
Pequod is the name of an Indian tribe
Moby Dick is a seafaring tale one of the
men the narrator says call me Ishmael
somebody ask him where he's from he says
it's not done on any map two places
never are Stubb gives no significance to
anything says everything is predestined
Ishmael has been on a sailing ship his
entire life calls the sailing ships he
has Harvard and Yale he keeps his
distance from people but typhoon hits
the Pequod Captain Ahab thinks it's a
good omen
Starbuck thinks it's a bad omen
considers killing Ahab as soon as the
storm ends a crew member falls from the
ship's mast and drowns foreshadowing was
to come a quaker pacifist priest who is
actually a bloodthirsty businessman
tells flask some men who received
injuries are led to God
others have led to bitterness everything
is mixed in all the myths the
judeo-christian Bible Hindu myths
British legends st. George prissiest
Hercules go Whalers Greek mythology the
gory business of cutting up a whale lots
of facts in this book geographical
knowledge whale oil good for coronation
of royalty noble families in the whaling
industry oil oil is used to anoint the
Kings history of the whale phrenology
classical philosophy pseudo scientific
theories justification for
discrimination everything thrown in and
none of it hardly rational highbrow
lowbrow chasing and losing chasing death
the great white whale where does a polar
bear
where is a white man the Emperor the
nemesis the embodiment of evil the
demented Kathryn who actually lost his
leg years ago trying to attack movie
with a knife we see only the surface of
things we can interpret what lies below
any way we see fit qu men walk around on
deck listening for mermaids and sharks
and vultures follow the ship reading
skulls and faces like you read a book
here's a face I put in funnier read it
if you can castigo says that he died and
was reborn his extra days our gift
he wasn't saved by Christ though he says
he was saved by a fellow man and a
non-christian is that he parodies the
resurrection when Starbuck tells a hab
that he shall let bygones be bygones
the angry captain snaps back speak that
to me a blaspheming man I'd strike the
Sun if it insulted me a hab two is a
poet of eloquence he says the path to my
fixed purpose is laid with iron rails
where my soul is grooved to run or these
lines all visible objects are bought
pasteboard masks quotable poetic phrases
that can't be beat finally I have spots
Bobby and the harpoons come out boats
are lured a halfs harpoon has been
baptized in blood Moby attacks a halfs
boat and destroys it next day he strikes
a movie again boats are lowered again
Moby attacks Ahab's boat again on a
third day another boat goes in more
religious allegory He is risen Moby
attacks one more time ramming the Pequod
and sinking it a hab gets tangled up in
the harpoon lines and is thrown out of
his boat into a watery grave its barrel
survives he's in the sea floating on a
coffin and that's about it that's the
whole story that team and all that it
implies would work its way into more
than a few of my songs
All Quiet on the Western Front was
another book that did all quiet on the
western front is a horror story this is
a book where you lose your childhood
your faith in a meaningful world and
your concern for individuals you're
stuck in a nightmare sucked up into a
mysterious whirlpool of death and pain
you're defending yourself from
elimination
you're being wiped off the face of the
map once upon a time you were an
innocent youth with big dreams about
being a concert pianist
once you loved life and the world and
now you're shooting it to pieces day
after day the Hornets bite you in worms
laughs your blood you're a cornered
animal you don't fit anywhere the
falling rain is monotonous this endless
assaults Pleasant gas nerve gas morphine
burning streams of gasoline scavenging
and scabbing for food influenza typhus
dysentery life is breaking down all
around you and the shells are whistling
this is the lower region of Hell mud
barbed wire rat filled trenches rats
eating the intestines of dead man
trenches filled with filth excrement
someone shouts hey you there stand and
fight who knows how long is nestled on
warfare has no limit your being
annihilated and that leg of yours is
bleeding too much you killed a man
yesterday and you spoke to his corpse
you told him after this is over you'll
spend the rest of your life looking
after his family who's profiting here
the leaders in the generals gained fame
and many other profits financially but
you drew the duty work one of your
comrades says wait a minute where are
you going and you say leave me alone
I'll be back
a minute then you walk out into the
woods of death hunting for a piece of
sausage you can't see how anybody in
civilian life has any kind purpose at
all
oh they're worries all the desires you
can't comprehend it mo machine guns
rattle more parts of bodies hanging from
wires more pieces of arms and legs and
skulls where butterflies perch on teeth
more hideous wounds pus coming out of
every pore loans wounds too big for the
body gas blowing cadavers and dead
bodies making retching noises death is
everywhere nothing else is possible
someone will kill you and use your dead
body for target practice boots too
they're your prized possession but soon
they'll be on somebody else's feet
there's froggies coming through the
trees merciless bastards
your cells are running out it's not fair
to come at us again so soon you say one
of your companions is laying in the dirt
and you are taken to the field hospital
someone else says you might save
yourself a trip what do you mean turn
him over you'll see what I mean
you wait to hear the news you don't
understand why the war isn't over the
Army is so strapped for replacement
troops at the drafting young boys who
are little military use but to draft
them anyway because they're running out
of man sickness and humiliation and bilk
in your heart you would betrayed by your
parents your school masters your
ministers and even your own government
the general with the slowly smoke cigar
aid you to turn you into a thug and a
murderer if you could you'd put a bullet
in his face
the commander as well you fantasized
that if you had the money you put up a
reward for any man who would take his
life by any means necessary and if he
should lose his life by doing that then
let the money go to his ass the colonel
- with his caveat his coffee
he's another one spends all his time in
the officers brothel you'd like to see
him stone dead - more Tommy's and
Johnny's with their whack for my daddy-o
and their whiskey of the jaws you kill
20 of them 20 more will spring up in
their place it just stinks in your
nostrils
you've come to despise that older
generation that set you out into this
madness into this torture chamber all
around you your comrades are dying dying
from abdominal wounds double amputations
shattered hip bones and you think I'm
only 20 years old but I'm capable of
killing anybody even my father if he
came at me yesterday you tried to save a
wounded messenger dog somebody shouted
don't be a fool one froggy is laying
gurgling at your feet you're stuck him
with a dagger in his stomach but the man
still lives you know you should finish a
job but you can't
you're on the real Iron Cross and the
Roman soldiers putting a sponge of
vinegar to your lips months passed by
you you're home on leave you can't
communicate with your father he said
you'd be a coward if you don't enlist
your mother too and your way back out
the door she says you be careful of
those french girls now more madness you
fight for a week or a month and you gain
10 yards and then the next month it gets
taken back all that culture from a
thousand years ago that philosophy that
wisdom Plato Aristotle Socrates what
happened to it it should have prevented
this your thoughts turned homework and
once again you're a schoolboy walking
through the tall poplar trees it's a
pleasant memory more bombs drop it on
you from blimps you got to get it
together now you can't even look at
anybody for fear of some miscalculation
the common grave there are no other
possibilities then you notice the cherry
blossoms and you see the nature is
unaffected by all this poplar trees the
red butterflies the fragile beauty of
flowers the Sun you see how nature is
indifferent to at all all the violence
and suffering and mankind nature doesn't
even notice it you're so alone that a
piece of shrapnel hits the side of your
head and you're dead you've been ruled
out crossed out you've been exterminated
I've put this book down close it up I
never wanted to read another war novel
again and I never did Charlie Poole from
North Carolina had a song that connected
to all this is called you ain't talking
to me and the lyrics go like this
I saw a sign in the window walking
uptown Monday
Johnny I'm you see the world is what it
had to say you'll see exciting places
with a jolly crew
you'll meet interesting people and learn
to kill them too oh you ain't talking to
me you ain't talking to me I may be
crazy and all that but I got a good
sense you see you ain't talking to me
you ain't talking to me killing where
the gun don't sound like fun you ain't
talking to me
The Odyssey is a Greek book whose themes
have worked its way into the balance of
light of songwriters homeward bound
green green grass of home home on the
range and my songs as well the Odyssey
is a strange adventurous tale of a grown
man trying to get home after fighting in
a war he's on that long journey home and
it's filled with traps and pitfalls he's
cursed to wander he's always getting
carried out to sea always having close
calls huge chunks of boulders rock his
boat he angers people he shouldn't those
troublemakers in his crew treachery his
men I turned into pigs and then they're
turned back into younger more handsome
men he's always trying to rescue
somebody
he's a travelin man but he's making a
lot of stops he's stranded on a desert
island he finds deserted caves and he
hides in them he meets giants that say
I'll eat you last and he escapes from
Giants he's trying to get back home but
he's tossed and turned by the winds
Restless winds chilly winds unfriendly
winds he travels far and then he gets
blown back he's always being warned of
things to come touching things he's told
not to there's two rows to take and
they're both bad both hazardous on one
you could drown and on the other you
could starve he goes into the narrow
streets with foaming whirlpools that
swallow him meat six headed monsters
with shock bang
Thunderbolt strike at him overhanging
branches that he makes a leap to reach
par to save himself among raging river
goddesses and gods protected but some
others want to kill him
he changes identities he's exhausted he
falls asleep and he's woken up by the
sound of laughter he tells his story to
strangers
he's been gone 20 years he was carried
off somewhere and left there drugs have
been dropped into his wine it's been a
hard road to travel in a lot of ways
some of these same things have happened
to you you two have had drugs dropped
into your wine you two have shared a bed
with the wrong woman you two have been
spellbound by magical voices sleep
voices with strange melodies you two
have come so far and have been so far
blown back and you've had close calls as
well you have angered people you should
not have and you two have rambled this
country all around and you've also felt
that he'll wind the wind that blows you
no good and that's still not all of it
when he gets back home things on any
better scoundrels have moved in and our
taking advantage of his wife's
hospitality and there's too many of them
and though he's greater than the mall
and the best of everything
best carpenter best hunter best expert
on animals best seaman his courage won't
save him but his trickery will all these
stragglers will have to pay for
desecrating his palace
he'll disguise himself as a filthy
beggar and a lowly servant kicks him
down the steps of arrogance and
stupidity the servants arrogance revolts
him but he controls his anger he's won
against a hundred but they'll all fall
even the strongest he was nobody and
when it's all said and done when he's
home at last he sits with his wife and
he tells her the stories so what does it
all mean myself and a lot of other
songwriters have been influenced by
these very same themes and they could
mean a lot of different things if a song
moves you that's all that's important I
don't have to know what a song means
I've written all kinds of things into my
songs and I'm not going to worry about
it what it all means
when Melville put all his Old Testament
biblical references scientific theories
Protestant doctrines and all that
knowledge of the sea and sailing ships
and whales into one story I don't think
he would have worried about it either
but it all means
John Donne as well the poet priest who
lived in the time of Shakespeare wrote
these words the cistal's and a batos of
her breasts not of two lovers but two
loves the nest I don't know what it
means either but it sounds good and you
want your songs to sound good when
Odysseus in the Odyssey visits the famed
warrior Achilles in the underworld
Achilles who traded a long life full of
peace and contentment for a short one
full of honour and glory tells Odysseus
it was all mistake
I just died that's all there was no
honor no immortality and that if he
could he would choose to go back and be
a lowly slave to a tenant farmer on
earth rather than be what he is a king
in the land of
and that whatever his struggles of life
were they were preferable to being here
in this dead place and that's what songs
are to our songs are alive in the land
of the living
the songs are unlike literature they're
meant to be sung not read the words in
Shakespeare's plays were meant to be
acted on the stage just as lyrics and
songs I meant to be some not read on a
page and I hope some of you get the
chance to listen to these lyrics the way
they were intended to be heard in
concert or on record or however people
are listening to songs these days I
returned once again to Homer who says
singing the old mute and do me tell the
story
you